[Music]
one interesting aspect of what's
happening now is they increase the use
of artificial artificial intelligence
both in the scientific study but also in
platforms like Facebook Google Google
Maps and so on so people often do not
realize that the newsfeed that they're
seeing is basically an AI artificial
intelligence that is just working hard
to keep them engaged as much as possible
right so way in a way by by interacting
with Facebook they're interacting with
artificial intelligence which is an
interesting thought because very often
people would ask me hey so when am I
going to start interacting with robots
right and like you're interacting with
robots for quite some time already you
just don't realize that right at what
you see on Facebook is basically a
product of an artificial intelligence
trying to make you happy and make you
engaged and now this has far-reaching
consequences let me give you an example
many people say hey you know like tools
are never better good they're morally
mutual take a knife knife is not better
good it's just humans that can use nice
for bad or good purposes now
interestingly people were saying the
same thing about artificial intelligence
they would say hey artificial
intelligence cannot be evil it's just
that the human user huerta visual
intelligence can be evil and can leash
out artificial intelligence to do evil
things but it's not true artificial
intelligence can in fact be evil
regardless of the intentions of the of
its administrators let me give you an
example when you set up an artificial
intelligence system you give it a goal
all right so if I'm Facebook I will set
my artificial intelligence system to
keep users engaged and well maximize
more my advertising revenues as well
right so I set up this very complicated
AI system that basically
optimizes your experience as a user
suggest friends to you suggest content
to you or on your newsfeed you know
shows your relevant advert and so on and
the goal of this AI system is to keep
you engaged now the very reason that we
use artificial intelligence is that
because the tasks that direct official
intelligence is dealing with are too
complicated for humans to deal with on
our own right so you could imagine
hiring millions of editors they would
sit down and try to optimize you know
your Facebook experience for you right
peak you know just just the stories for
you but obviously this is just not
doable so what we having here we replace
potential human editors with AI that has
a goal of keeping you engaged now the
problem is that the goal might be
morally neutral or positive like keeping
you engaged with Facebook but the ways
of achieving this goal AI developed on
its own so no one retells exactly AI how
to keep you engaged in AI will come up
with ways of its own now the problem is
that those ways might be ethically
questionable fake news for instance we
had this epidemic zone of fake use on
Facebook why because AI recognized that
if it shows you this content then you
will basically be engaged in you be like
oh my god this is the story's crazy and
people would command and some people say
that's true some other we would say oh
that's rubbish so basically what
happened that a I boosted user
engagement realize in an excellent way
the goal that each designers you know
asked it to achieve but achieved it in
ways that you know humans will probably
see as potentially unethical
[Music]
so the idea is behind the algorithm like
when you hear machine learning or neural
networks or deep learning networks ideas
behind those models those artificial
intelligence models are really simple
you could explain them to a
seven-year-old really easily but what
happens is that those very simple rules
that are used to create those models
which are basically just very often this
is just multiplication and addition that
I've been used to build those predictive
models but then when you add up millions
of elements in your equation it or even
hundreds of elements honestly in your
equation it's very easy for a computer
to work with it's completely impossible
for a human being to comprehend which
creates an interesting situation in
which you have individuals and societies
making decisions based on what AI told
them to do without having an
understanding why this decision has been
made Google Maps you drive to work in
the morning Google Maps tells you how to
go there you kind of don't really
question the Machine anymore you know
that it's way better than your friends
neighbors and partners in telling you
how to beat the traffic
now how this algorithm works exactly you
know we know other the rules driving
this algorithm but how exactly the
decision for you has been made this
might be already beyond human
comprehension
how the stories were chosen for you for
your Facebook newsfeed we know the
simple rules that we ask the machine to
follow but exact intricacies of this
machine learning model and that is
actually driving the content driving the
choices of the content to appear in
newsfeed beyond our comprehension we
have now computers analyzing x-rays in
order to detect cancer and suggest the
best treatment and we know that those
computers are more accurate than doctors
and making those decisions and we have
very limited understanding why exactly
this particular decision has been made
well you can ask the model model be like
hey this is really simple here is 1
million numbers that drove me to make
this decision can a human being
comprehend you know 1 million or even
you know 100 numbers simultaneously our
brains did not evolve to work in this
way quartz makes the decisions make the
decisions about whether to let people go
and how long the sentence should be and
whether to grant you parole based on the
outcome of an algorithm so obviously to
judge that you know slums the hammer
down the whatever podium but at the end
of the day there is a little screen here
and the screen says they are written
calculated that this person should get
seven years in prison or you should not
grant parole to this person because
their chances of reoffending us seventy
or eighty percent and this number is a
product of hundreds of variables that go
into it so no human being can understand
is a mathematical equation so it's it's
a deterministic a process we know that
it works because you can apply it to
previous cases in fact it works for the
benefit of humans because what it
happens is that when the when the judges
when judge just sees you for a few
minutes and you know has a few seconds
to kind of skim through your case and
you are unlikely to be black then you
basically just go to prison because like
this just a assumption like that just
another 100 people in prison who cares
right this is the safest option but now
what happens is there is this algorithm
there that says in fact you know your
intuition is to put them in prison but
they're unlikely to be offense so why
don't you let them go so we have
evidence that those algorithms in in
fact I'm making prisons more empty
because you know they let judges be more
liberal with the choices but on the
other hand we have the length of your
sentence being decided not by a human
being anymore but by a computer the time
of an algorithm is way cheaper than the
time of a judge so what will happen now
it is actually prosecution or there they
will hit it so counties
iris software are a few companies in the
u.s. that produce this software and it's
basically big data software they analyze
life histories and cases case materials
and you know some demographic variables
like you know number of siblings number
of children how many convictions we had
in the past and whatnot and then they
check okay so how likely this person was
to reoffend and you build this huge
statistical model and the basic is okay
a person that has three siblings and did
not have these offence in the past or
whatnot you know it's unlikely to Rhea
fence where don't you let them go and
the judge and the prosecutor will
actually give it to the judge it's kind
of printed out of this third blow
certified well accept it in a given
jurisdiction computer program and the
judge would be like you know okay now
there's an interesting psychological
phenomena here because if the judge
disagrees with the program there's only
one way in which judge can disagree with
the program namely the judge could
decide to give you a longer sentence
because now imagine no human being would
risk saying oh software says this person
is likely to reoffend I will let them go
why because then if the judge takes a
responsibility for shortening the
sentence against the advice of the
computer overloads which basically means
that you know you don't have judges with
agreeing with the algorithm because why
would they take this responsibility if
the person we offense they can always
say look according to the model it was
unlikely to happen I just follow the
advice of the model but if the model
says this person is going to reoffend
and judge lets you go and then someone
comes after you and says hey why did you
let this guy go you what did you say
you acted against the what the algorithm
said so literally we have the cases of
freedom and and imprisonment decided now
by a mathematical formula that no one
understands because people don't
understand how those Samoas work it's
highly disappointing but the fact is
that humans are just no better judges of
each other then algorithms are and if
anything algorithms are better judges of
us the humans are because algorithms are
not sexist
I'm not racist I note ages and I'm
basically not biased against you that we
have so much evidence if you're a black
defendant in a white defendant exactly
the same history black just basically
will always get a larger sentence now
for a computer it will not happen
because computer doesn't care about the
color of your skin so you could argue
that basically employing algorithm in
such cases and we have a lot of evidence
actually lowers the sentence length and
lowers the real reoffending rates so
it's great for the society and great for
the defendants the problem that I have
with it and I don't know how to solve it
is that we follow those decisions and we
have no idea how those decisions has
been made
[Music]